he was one of the UN's top human rights
officials Assistant Secretary General
Andrew Gilmore seen here with Ranga
refugees in Bangladesh served the
International Organization for 30 years
now he stepped down and he's given a
scathing assessment of the state of
human rights particularly in Israel and
the Palestinian territories how bad is
the situation on the ground particularly
in Gaza for for ordinary people it is
absolutely appalling I would say in in
Gaza the actual physical condition of
people is is indescribable it is to me
just scandalous of the world allows that
siege it's a siege essentially I mean
it's the word that when I was in the UN
we couldn't use that without getting a
lot of protest but effectively that's
what it is
goods are not properly allowed in and
people are not allowed out he agreed
with the assessment the situation is
similar to the way white controlled
South Africa was run until the beginning
of the 1990s apartheid it's very hard to
see that situation and not regarded as
of a segregation that is so profound
that it that it reaches the level of
apartheid but I've never seen a greater
deliberate humiliation of an entire
people and that that has been a very
consistent trend that I've seen is that
it gets worse but it seems to be that
humiliation is almost part of the the
game plan so why is there not more
global criticism of Israel's actions at
the UN and in the Security Council the
u.s. takes Israel side and under the
Trump administration their support has
been unwavering even when Israel killed
more than 70 people in one day at the
Gaza fence the former US ambassador on
the day that doesn't were shot through
the fence with sniper rifles they were
no danger at all most of them I mean
they were shot and looting a number of
children do some basileus that is very
zactly with restraint I mean if that is
restraint I would hate to see
than you know the under strain mode UN
officials are normally very measured
with the words they use particularly on
this issue one that's so politically
charged the real views of a top official
now no longer in his post a rare and
powerful James BAE's al-jazeera at the
United Nations